agit de 70 ans s'apprête à subir son
deuxième prosté pour agression sexuelle
l'ancien producteur purge déjà une peine
de 23 ans d'emprisonnement pour des
agressions et des viols commis dans
l'État de New York et sa possible
condamnation pour des crimes similaires
perpétrés en Californie entre 2004 et
2013 pourrait lui valoir jusqu'à 140 ans
de prison de plus 5 années se sont
écoulés après l'enquête du New York
Times qui a révélé au grand public les
agissements de lancer Mania d'Hollywood
cette année ou des milliers de femmes
dans le monde on prépare au mouvement
MiTo moi aussi
selon l'avocate de Juripop le mouvement
a permis plusieurs avancées à chaque
mouvement de dénonciation on remarque
une hausse des plaintes des
dénonciations formelles à la police puis
deuxièmement c'est à ses vagues de
dénonciation le qu'on doit les
modifications dans le système de justice
je pense au projet pilote de tribunaux
spécialisés qui sont en train de se
déployer à travers le Québec plusieurs
survivants d'agression ont eu aussi le
sentiment d'être plus entendu je pense
j'ai reçu comme une centaine de
témoignages de personnes qui me disaient
oh je me retrouve vraiment dans ce que
tu dis c'est super intéressant parce que
il y a des personnes qui sont dans leur
processus judiciaire qui se retrouvent
dans ces communautés donc des personnes
qui parlent de leur expérience passée
alors que elles elles sont en train de
le vivre au moment même où elles
entendent ces témoignages ça leur donne
souvent de la force
encaissé l'acquittement de Gilbert Rozon
à son procès pour viol et atteinte à la
pudeur en 2020 il voit certains
enseignements même en étant victime même
en ayant été piétiné en ayant été assez
servi je me dis debout maintenant puis
ça je pense que c'est ce que les
victimes veulent être debout puis
regarder leur agresseur en face disait
c'est terminé tu n'en feras plus
d'audithme ce que moi je pense c'est que
cette conversation là ne pourra plus
s'éteindre maintenant parce que selon
elle moi aussi aperçi bien au-delà du
monde de la culture il concerne
désormais tous les travailleurs les
rapports homme-femme et l'ensemble de la
société ici Gabriel prout prado-canada
Montréal